the Transparency International
corruption perceptions index came out
this week and its outlook for Latin
America is bleak no country is
significantly improved its score since
2017.
the organization says an overall failure
by leaders to act against corruption and
strength and public institutions has
left the door open for criminal networks
to bully and co-opt politicians
Nicaragua Cuba Guatemala they all sank
to new lows in Guatemala's case after
briefly showing the way forward with the
United nations-backed anti-corruption
commission that was dissolved in 2019
Haiti's in trouble too with no elected
government officials and its capital
largely overrun by gangs
but the absolute bottom of the pile
according to Transparency International
is Venezuela I asked the organization's
director there Mercedes de Freitas why
in contrast to the rest of the countries
there is no space in which Venezuelans
can go to ask for justice or their
rights the co-optation of the
institutions is totaled by the group in
power and the systems for justice don't
do their job on the contrary they are
guarantors of impunity
it's the most extreme case perhaps but
it's common to hear in Latin America
that corruption is a cancer near
impossible to root out
in Latin America expectations are so low
that people in some countries actually
have a saying Robert perro Assi
regarding politicians and it means well
he steals but at least he does something
but if that changed if electorates
started expecting even demanding that
their politicians did things for them
without stealings might things improve
in this region
perhaps Uruguay also in the region shows
that they could it's a rare of
light for Latin America it has the same
transparency score in the indexes Canada
while Uruguay is one of our top
performers in several years and it is
not a coincidence that the country is a
strong democracy it's a more a United
society and institutions work well what
does that mean it means that checks and
balances operate well it means that they
have a Judiciary that is a strong and
independent there's a reward for that
Uruguay has the highest per capita
income and lowest rate of inequality in
Latin America
that alone seems worth fighting for if
other governments here are interested
John Holman Al Jazeera Mexico City